now why did i bother introducing this
question
by showing you how to use the
discriminant for the
previous question because when you want
to work out the restrictions
on this locus okay the methods we've
already been using they break down
okay let's think about the methods for a
second by thinking about
um the two kinds of locus that we've
been interacting with already
so when you've got a red
okay when you take any parabola right
and you've got some
chords on it okay we've already sort of
said it's self-evident
that the midpoint of those chords must
be within the
parabola okay and likewise or
actually conversely because it's the
opposite if you're getting
interceptions of tangents we've said
wherever they are
they've got to intersect outside the
parabol
yeah okay but there's a problem with our
question
this one okay i want you to draw for
yourself three sets of parabolas
on your page next to each other in a row
if you've got a template bonus points
draw up three parabolas
and let's illustrate something
still the same question
now just to um just to save you some
time unless you've already done it just
draw the parabolas don't even worry
about
the x and y axes okay i'm just
interested in the shape
okay and we're going to draw some
normals on these in a second right so
draw
three parabolas next to each other
okay now let's think about this remember
what a normal is
it's perpendicular to the tangent it's
the line perpendicular to the tangent at
a particular point
now where is it going to why well
uh in this middle parabola that you've
drawn right let's put this case in
what this particular question has told
us is
for certain kinds of normals right their
point of intersection where they collide
is going to be back on the original
parabola
okay so use your ruler try and do this
as neatly as possible
but pick a couple of points like like
these ones okay
and maybe get them in different colors
if you've got them okay
do it on this middle one and if you draw
it right
the intersection of the normals like say
these two let's draw
this one that's not straight at all and
this one okay so pop in like a little
right angle here
just to illustrate what they are okay
the intersection of these holes is
right on the problem that you started
okay however it's not that hard
to think of cases where this doesn't
happen that they don't intersect
on the parabola can anyone draw for me
how can we make normals that don't
intersect on the problem
inside the problem okay so if you've got
um two normals let's just leave that one
in place sorry i should have
held on to this let's put that one still
there
okay so that's that's a normal but if
you take the normal from the
opposite direction right you flip it
over quite clearly
quite clearly the normals intersect
within the parabola
that's true but i'm thinking about we're
trying to make geometric arguments that
apply to all kinds of normals
right you're right that doesn't make it
make sense in this case
but you'll see why it's important so
they can intersect inside they can
intersect on the parabola
could they possibly intersect outside
the parabola
and so yeah what kind of condition would
we need for them
to sit outside
sort of sort of close together but not
too close together right because if
they're too close together
um you know they'll just they'll still
intersect inside right but if they're
close together the right
amount and you've got depending on what
kind of focal length you have and so on
okay
they're going to do something like this
you'll have one that chops through
like that and you have your right angle
and the other one
is going to now i'm not sure if i'm
drawing this well enough but
you're just a problem
no that's that's pretty right angle-ish
isn't it
that's convincing enough right so have a
look at this
okay intersection of normals
if you want to put like a little
subheading over these three diagrams
okay
it can happen within
or on or outside
a parabola can go anywhere you'd like
right
so we can't make the same kind of
geometric argument that we could with
midpoints
which are inside or intersection changes
which are outside
you just yeah you can't do it okay so
that leaves us with
the discriminant that's the only way we
can do this okay
so how should we find the restrictions
yeah that's right this this is the
special case that i was talking about
before
remember i said you've got to have these
two methods you can prefer one that's
fine
but you've got to know how to do both
this is why okay
right let's find the restriction i'm
going to go with this equation here
i think it's faster yeah and it's less
it's less mental gymnastics to be honest
right now this is the equation we had i
think this was the final equation we had
for x
yes okay so what do i want
to get this into a form that i can use
the discriminant on what do i have to
get rid of
i've got to get rid of a parameter okay
so in order to do that
i've rubbed it off already i'm going to
use the fact that
pq is equal to two
right so if i wanted to get rid of q
i guess i'd say q is equal to two on p
right so oops
okay so uh what can i go through here
let me just expand it first
to p minus
4 on p and there's my x
you can start to see the pattern right
you often get this fraction business so
i've got to multiply through my p and
that's what makes the quadratic
okay so i have p x
okay yes so let's put it all on one side
px plus four okay
for real value real solutions of p
okay
the discriminant is greater than or
equal to zero okay so
b squared is x squared
minus 4 a
c that's greater than 2 for 0.
okay so x squared 4
8 32 so it's not quite as neat
okay but what's the square root of 32
what's that work at you
4 root 2 yeah so when you're taking this
parabola
you're going to be less than the
negative
value or greater than a positive a
or like i said before you can be fancy
you can use absolute value
to express that all in one go okay
but that's it okay so just to review
we went through the same way but to find
the restriction because the intersection
of the norms is a special case okay
geometric arguments it's not that they
don't work
um you can actually use them but it's
just far too complicated you can't just
say it's
it fits one of these cases okay it has
to do with the fact that
this point zero minus two that we've
chosen right
that's terrible zero minus two if you
think about the kinds
of chords you can form
that pass through here okay um you know
for example you can form
listen to your stick you could form this
chord right
or you could form this chord or you
could form
this chord but at a certain point you
can't form chords anymore
right because you know the lines that
you draw through they're just going to
go push
and they'll never reconnect okay so what
you've got is actually just
coming through and there are no two
points that i can use to say well here's
normal number one and here's normal
number two okay so this restriction
saying it has to be far out this way and
far out that way
it's actually blocking out this part in
the middle where you just can't make
normals
that go through that point which is what
you were mentioning before you can't you
can't do these kinds of
words okay so there is a geometric
argument but it's so convoluted
you might as well just use the
descriptive method because it makes
sense you can stand by the algebra and
say i see why
it works okay um did you have a question
yeah
um is it usually greater than zero
it has to yes because what we want right
um is for p to exist we want it to work
we don't want it to be some kind of
imaginary floating off thing so it's
always
greater than zero right for these kinds
of questions yeah because what we want
is real solutions
and the condition for real solutions is
the square root being greater than don't
you always want those solutions
no i mean if the question was one of
those contrived ones where it's like
here's
a quadratic you know
okay and they say
find the values of k that make the roots
not real
right so you would need the discriminant
to be zero and then you solve that for k
right but in this case we always want
real solutions question
oh yeah is there any other um
this is this is the common case and to
say that this is the common case of
enemy misnomer
because it's not common at all this
hardly ever comes up but
i wanted to show it to you you know have
it on record so that you can be like
well i know this is the widow one
this is where it comes up if it comes up
i'll be ready for it